on a une nouvelle chronique vraiment
pour se faire plaisir de temps en temps
avec janick tremblay on va retourner
dans le passé à la recherche des gadgets
qui on trouve connu leur heure de gloire
avant de tomber en désuétude ont décidé
d'appeler ça le cimetière des gadgets
ils commencent à être plein mais encore
de la place ça commence donc aujourd'hui
janyk avec un joie qui a été populaire
il ya quelques années oui on va voir si
vous allez être mesure d identifier vous
et les auditeurs seulement aux sons
ça vous dit quelque chose
oui c'est la réponse je réponde adresse
à tous je n'aurais pas là ce sont les
tamagotchi oui moi j'étais chanceux mais
mais mais en fait tu es trop jeune pour
les salades vous savez c'est un animal
virtuel compte devait donc en prendre
soin vous l'aurez compris virtuellement
ça ça voulait dire le faire naître le
faire éclore ça venait souvent dans un
petit bidule en forme d'oeuf ça va les
nourrir la muse et le faire dormir ça se
présentait sur un petit écran monochrome
qui était aussi il faut le dire un
porte-clés ce qui faisait leur dis
toujours sur vous et ses savates est
épouvantablement populaire cette
affaire-là vous dites entre 96 et 2010
le moment où on est vraiment tombé dans
le vrai des clés il s'en est vendu
quelque chose comme 70 millions un peu
partout à travers le monde imaginez il
avait même leurs dessins animés en asie
qui met en vedette deux buts à melwood
il ya des gens qui disaient que ça
apprenait le sens des responsabilités
aux enfants mais parce que le talent est
de nourrir mais les tv l'équipe veut
mourir séance en occupait pas donc et
mais les experts il faut le dire j'étais
assez divisés là dessus il y en a
plusieurs qui avance écoutez c'est
totalement virtuel et ses compétences là
pour reprendre un vocable qu'on connaît
bien son patates sont pas transversaux
vraiment dans quel pays a été un temps
donc où ça faisait beaucoup parler les
tamagotchi on a fait un petit tour dans
le passé c'est ce qui nous permet les
archives de radio-canada on écoute un
peu ensemble
le tamagotchi celui qui est original la
forme de 1,9 il est à peu près
introuvable à toronto je sais pas ce que
j'ai fait une dizaine de magasins en fin
de semaine quand mon bébé dino ou a
besoin de quelque chose un petit bip bip
premiers beats mon bébé dit new adda fin
un autre bien par la suite les babys de
nauzan voulait jouer cette fois là mais
il a perdu le leur et que les prêts ni
le confirmer depuis deux jours
l'ancien mannequin sager peut s'avérer
une bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose
pour un fabricant de jouets prenez le
cas du petit poussin électronique qu'on
appelle le tamagotchi certains acheteurs
à qui j'ai parlé la semaine dernière et
un disque c'est un jouet qui sera
populaire très longtemps de nouveaux
tamagotchi qui vont arriver sur le
marché et cette fois ci sont un peu plus
sophistiqué un peu plus évolué yvon plus
de civet de relations intimes avec leurs
congénères vont passer de l'amitié l
amour voyons jusqu'au mariage et dans
certains cas un bébé risque eux-mêmes
d'apparaître sur l'écran un bébé
tamagotchi ils vont se vendre comment
ils vont faire accoucher la pauvre dame
à gauche alors écoutez la sexualité du
tamagotchi on me donne pas les détails
ce qu'un restes de table vous savez la
compagnie qui était à l'origine de tout
ça bandaï a annoncé un retour pour 2014
pendant ce mois au japon s'est encore
populaire chez certaines jeunes filles
mais c'est à peu près mort en maintenant
depuis l'avènement des téléphones
multifonctions et des applications faut
dire il ya quelques irréductibles qui
continuent d'acheter de ces bidules sur
ebay mais vous savez ce qu'on dit dans
la vie rien ne se perd tout se
transforme il ya une application sur
l'app store donc vous pouvez avoir un
tamagotchi sur votre téléphone joyeux
comme ça
mais le vrai tamagotchi d'aujourd'hui sa
carnation hoya et c'est le fourbi savez
c'est une petite boule de poils animé au
toutou qui est pourvu de capteurs qui
interagit donc davantage avec les
enfants ont écouté
les réactions de forme ils sont
imprévisibles et surprendront quand tu
vas le chatelier et caresser lui tirer
là qui coule agitée
salut ferdi
tu peux nourrir torby avec ton joie et
avec l'application furby disponible
gratuitement sur l'apple store utilise
aussi la pluie pour traduire du service
aux français
- changé
c'est convaincu d'aller télécharger sont
livrés à l'échéance fatale agathe à
mon niveau je pense et puis on s'était
mieux que le tamagotchi finalement notre
réalisateur voulait qu'on se laisse en
musique là dessus et pas la musique du
tamagotchi alors écoutez on écoute
petit risque d'aller me